hey guys i'm ryan right and alyssa be
crazy today 1up box fun stuff i forgot
what the theme is but it's gonna be fun
because all their [ __ ] is [ __ ]
awesome alyssa is my co-host today she
will be unveiling what the items are
hello Alyssa there's usually a little
thing in there like a paper that will
tell you what the theme is
yeah can you find that first don't tell
me what the products are just find out
what the theme is yeah but you don't get
any presents they're all for me theme is
justice justice justice okay alright
don't okay so I'm looking at the toys
for description the description is gonna
be pretty apparent through the unveiling
of the toy why don't you let me be
thorough
I got a copyright strike and I want to
make sure this video is less than 15
minutes alright male the first item
start from least interesting the most
interesting of course I just grabbed
something you know if it's my hands
alright let's do it that way then ah oh
cool
sweet really cute um Donatello right not
Donatello what the [ __ ] wrong with me
Leonardo Leonardo that's cool I got a
collection of toys now I think you put
your your penis in this little slot
right there yeah it's for kids oh yeah
that's really gross high supersoft penis
Stoppers Oh
see ya pencil topic it does look like
the work be all good penis yeah I could
squish them together it could look like
that but but pencil works too
anyway Leonardo toy haha I had this you
don't for a second one next one cuz your
eyes oh it's one of them toys yeah
oh sweet got a wind-up lantern over here
oh that's pretty [ __ ] cool wind up
green lantern I got so many Batman toys
already another DC these which other
ones do have well I don't have a wind-up
toy I haven't I have a Daryl wind-up toy
that's the one yeah I never opened the
boxes though to unwind them but today
we're gonna do it
Green Lantern in action people yeah and
he moves as slow as the Ryan Reynolds
movie perform at the boss office it was
my favorite but yeah we're not gonna go
into this right now Alyssa
it's a horrible film ok ok you're gonna
love this I'm not even gonna make you
close your eyes all right I don't have
sunglasses
Batman shades up I didn't even know they
made these oh [ __ ] that's awesome
those are so you it's not even funny wow
this is totally my style where's the
shoes Wow Wow
you look besides from the profiles yeah
the yellow yellow they're at the symbol
this is cool I also feel like I'm at a
you know a gay disco club in Germany or
something like that but okay that's cool
that's really cool no you need to wear
with pride and confidence cuz you are
all about man be the Batman I'm I'm
nothing like the real Batman combats
right I'm a [ __ ] alright cool cool and
this will probably be my favorite item
maybe even more than the shirt actually
this is really cool look it reflects
perfectly - that is so cool it reflects
perfectly
oh wow they're really cool hey you got
tattoos Oh what cool tattoos they have
they got one of them Nintendo moms they
got Rafael's sighs no yeah whatever they
got a lightsaber they got Thor's hammer
they got Wolverines claws they got the
does Zelda the link shield oh my god it
wasn't really cool I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna give Alyssa a present right
now all right you can have this one
Melissa gets Zelda as as much as I want
you to copyright strike don't forget to
listen don't forget okay we'll do it
after the video is done Jesus 1up box
July 2015 justice oh cool you got a
bunch of different super I came up with
a shirt that's like this I know if you
guys can't see it but it's pretty
[ __ ] sweet oh sweet Oh princess
double-oh-seven ha ha Princess Leia
that's cause this a magnet yeah oh sweet
that's really [ __ ] cool all right I
gotta get more Star Wars collectibles
that's awesome okay sure last one
ready unveil it yeah what is it I can
see super Rangers that is awesome I am
so gonna rock this shirt oh my god that
is awesome that is so cool surprise I've
never seen something like this before
that's so cool Wow
okay well if you guys want thank you 1up
box you guys [ __ ] Rock
1up box rocks my cock's what if you guys
want to win a box you can go to the
description box there's a referral link
I put down there go ahead get a 1up box
Instagram that you got it to me so
I know you got it and I know some of you
guys have already gone and it's so
Instagram it to me let's see what we can
share together that other people are not
having because we're the special ones
were the better ones in life it's a
special bond this is very is that only
one of box people understand the rest of
you you mean nothing I'm joking
people take me too seriously sometimes
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Elissa be crazies channel
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter or vine you have a
periscope yet I don't but I need to get
one follow me on periscope follow us
there on our social networks because um
it's a lot of fun stuff and Alyssa you
might even might not suspect this but
she posts a ton of bikini photos it's
true so many bikini it's what I live for
I'm secretly a bikini model and you know
it's it doesn't seem like it I don't put
on that face that front oh come on
right come on show them the goods Alyssa
show them the goods show them they're
good I'm trying to get more views right
now I'm trying to show you know like
Tyrone was like talking to me on the
phone he's like oh brandi is she the one
with the boobs and I was like no that's
Alyssa Alyssa did yeah you're the boobs
that's your life is known by the boobs
what is that it's a compliment
from a male perspective I'm just a
walking pair of boobs boobs
oh jeez how do you and Dan fool around
when you say like Oh baby touch my boobs
well please my boobs no oh yeah the
squeezer moves the lips
oh here don't do that